elles se comptent par dizaines à la
lisière de cette forêt près de vittel
christiane lui a tout à fait la
découverte de cet amas de bouteilles
plastiques lors d'une simple balade à
l'automne 2014
au début cette professeur d'anglais à la
retraite n'imaginais pas que le talus au
dessus de sa tête était en fait une
décharge sauvage
face à la gravité de sa découverte
christiane vue à tous amenez-le enquête
on a ramassé des bouteilles et on a vu
qu'elles étaient toutes estampillées
sgbc la société des eaux minérales de
vittel et qui a été racheté par nestlé
plus tard ce qui m'inquiète c'est où
est-ce qu'ils vont les emmener et parce
que on n'a pas vraiment en france de
deux usines pour traiter les plastiques
comme ça surtout que c'est des très
vieux plastiques désagréger et tout donc
salle
que faire de tout ça il y à 7 ans
christiane voeux à tous a alerté la
mairie de vittel et nestlé
l'entreprise suisse a discrètement
tenter de faire le ménage mais dès que
la partie visible des décharges a été
enlevé tout s'est arrêté
pour bernard schmitt porte-parole du
collectif aux 88 cette situation est une
catastrophe pour la nappe phréatique
vite et l'oise
on est en fait sur l'impluvium de witten
c'est à dire que tout les lieux toute la
pluie ils entendent pas mal aujourd'hui
qui tombent ici s'infiltrent dans les
nappes qui sont exploités par le par
nestlé a vital l'eau s'infiltre dans les
monticules de plastique mais je crois
qu'il faut ne pas voir que les
monticules de plastique mais c'est les
fausses qui ont été creusés à l'époque
selon les témoignages
on a fait des gigantesque fosse et on a
mené jour après jour du pvc par des
camions et on brûlait ce pv c'est depuis
de nombreuses années nestlé soupçonné
d'être derrière ces dépôts sauvages un
secret bien gardé dans une région
frappée par l'exode rural et où les 900
emplois du géant suisse pèsent de tout
leur poids
d'autres communes autour de vittel sont
aussi concernés c'est le cas à crins
villiers ou le maire bernard albert fait
confiance à la multinationale pour
dépolluer ses terres et cela m'avait
contacté donc ils m'ont dit qu'il
s'occuperait de cette affaire leur fais
entièrement confiance
on a besoin aussi nestlé dans la région
qui fait vivre beaucoup de personnes
outre ces décharges nestlé via sa
filiale agrivert a racheté d'emilie
ha de terres agricoles pour asseoir sa
domination didier thouvenin fait partie
de la dizaine d'agriculteurs qui refuse
de se mettre à genoux face à la
multinationale
aujourd'hui nestlé est le dieu de de la
région et ceux qui refusent de se mettre
à genoux devant lui on veulent
exterminer économiquement je dire c'est
pas réellement un combat c'est d'un
comté ya des gens qui ont des moyens
financiers colossaux et qu'ils ont avec
eux l'administration et les politiques
et de l'autre côté il ya des gens qu'on
appelle les moyens de survivre
cc oui c'est plus une extermination
certes économique qu'a combat la
direction du géant de l'eau a reconnu il
ya peu sa responsabilité dans neuf
décharges illégales autour de vittel
contacté par la rédaction de rtl france
nestlé annonce avoir mis en place un
plan d'action pour retirer ces déchets
nestlé waters s'est engagé à faire ce
qu'il faut et à prendre les mesures
d'assainissement approprié pour les
anciens sites de dépôts de déchets dont
elle a hérité sur ses propriétés et qui
date des années 1960 1970
cette période est antérieure à
l'acquisition par nestlé waters de
l'entreprise est de la responsabilité de
ces opérations
nous continuerons à travailler pour que
nos initiatives environnementales
continuent à contribuer à la protection
du territoire vosgien la société serait
qu'à filiale de veolia spécialisée dans
la gestion des déchets est en charge
d'analyser les terres où se situe
certaines de ces décharges sauvages
selon nestlé les premiers résultats
doivent être présenté début septembre
aux élus locaux et aux services de
l'état